hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast collectin 3 a step towards a
clear pathway in heart failure
management i'm judy oracle Everts and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
we are delighted to bring you this
educational weds web seminar presented
by laggards and sponsored by Abbott
Abbott is committed to helping live the
best possible life through the power of
Health for more than 125 years Abbott
has brought new products and
technologies to the world in nutrition
diagnostics medical devices and branded
generic pharmaceuticals that create more
possibilities for more people and all
stages of life Abbott is a global leader
in in vitro diagnostics offering a broad
portfolio spanning immunoassay clinical
chemistry zoology blood screening
molecular bio identification point of
care and informatics for more
information please visit Abbott comm we
have a few important announcements
before we begin this webcast is designed
to be interactive and we encourage you
to ask questions during the event you
can submit questions by typing them in
the Q&A box which can be found by
clicking on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
we'll try to answer as many questions as
we can you can enlarge the slide window
by clicking on the screen icon in the
lower right hand corner of the slide
window if you have any technical
problems viewing or hearing this
presentation please click on the support
button at the top right of your
presentation window or submit your
problem through the green Q&A button
lower left I would now like to introduce
today's speaker dr. Peter McCullough dr.
McCullough directs cardiovascular
education and research for the Baylor
healthcare system and is a vice chief of
medicine at the alert University Medical
Center in Dallas Texas and a principal
faculty in internal medicine put Texas
A&M University Health Sciences Center he
is an internationally recognized
authority on the role of chronic kidney
disease as a cardiovascular risks
with over 1,000 publications I will now
turn it over to dr. McCullough for his
presentation well thank you and thanks
to each and every one of you for taking
time out of your day to attend this
webinar titled collectin 3 a step
towards clear pathway in heart failure
management and I'd say just at the
outset that we are the in the midst of
really a heart failure pandemic in terms
of hospitalizations resource utilization
and the importance of heart failure to
both outpatient and inpatient venues of
care that span primary care and
specialty care and this topic is timely
and I think important for us to follow
the development of in vitro diagnostics
to aid in the prognosis and management
are terribly important so as a
disclosure this program sponsored by
Abbott and on behalf of Abbott and it's
consistent with its applicable FDA
requirements so I'll follow this outline
and make a few points with respect to
each one of these bullets and the
overall spectrum of myocardial disease
is important to consider because
patients with congestive heart failure
have degrees of stability and then to
compensate and it's now known that the
decompensation takes several days or
several weeks to materialize at home and
that each event of care is shown in this
graphic is costly heart flare
hospitalizations are costly in terms of
a care of patients in the hospital and
the aftercare and whether that financial
burden is shouldered by the government
or private sources of funding the point
is it can't be made less expensive and
less heart failure hospital
Asians are reduced now
the manifestations of heart failure
whether it be ischemic or non ischemic
in etiology ultimately are attributable
to the progression of myocardial
fibrosis that is replacement of heart
muscle cells with fibrotic material
being collagen fir Berlin and other
structural replacement proteins in place
of myocardial cells and this slide shows
a patient with heart failure as you can
see on the lower panel having
considerable amount of blue material in
between the spaces of the cardiomyocytes
that is basically fibrotic materialist
non contractile and the upper panel
shows that a local mediator called
collectin 3 is directing a lot of this
activity stimulating fibroblasts to
proliferate into Maya fibroblasts and
laid down the extracellular matrix so we
know a local pair can factor is a
principal director of the activities
there are certainly other cytokines and
growth factors that are involved but
collecting 3 appears to be a very strong
signal the cardiac fibrosis as shown in
this slide is responsible for left
ventricular stiffness as well as the
synchrony or disordered contraction of
the ventricle it's also responsible for
tissue heterogeneity and a principle
called
an isotropy or unequal conduction of
depolarization that ultimately leads to
reentry so cardiac fibrosis is
responsible for the substrate that leads
to sudden death as well as the substrate
that leads to heart failure whether it
be impairment of systole or diastole
we believe that fibrosis is also
occurring in the vasculature and that
increased stiffness creates an increased
after load on the heart and further
contributes to heart flare of all
ideologies now galectins 3 as I've
already introduced is an important
measureable factor reflecting fibrosis
and what we know about collectin 3 it's
one of a family of lectin
there are about a dozen of these
described in mammals they are major
directors of healing so if one has has a
skin abrasion or cut collectin threes
are directing fibrosis in the skin but
an internal organ injury they also are
directing fibrosis and repair of
internal organs the gene is sequenced
and known it's largely secreted by
macrophages and then to a lesser extent
other cell lines is primarily a
paracrine factor it's rapidly in turn
internalized by cell surface beta
integrins and then it does turn on
intracellular signaling a fibroblast via
the intrud cellular signal called
tgf-beta or transforming growth factor
beta and increases the cell cycle
so these fibroblasts convert to myofiber
blasts and lay down copious amounts of
collagen one which is cross-linked into
mature collagen which is basically a
permanent structure and collectin 3 is
proven to be pathogenic meaning that in
translational studies that clearly
directs and rise fibrosis in the heart
it does have a natural inhibitor that is
currently being studied as potentially a
treatment down the line now a fibrosis
and adverse cardiac remodelling as shown
here in response to myocardial injury
for instance a myocardial infarction or
a heart attack the macrophages shown as
these blue cells in the myocardium
secrete collectin 3 in response to
injury and as they release collectin 3
they stimulate Myo fibroblasts to
proliferate and the proliferation then
results in more of these cells and then
deposition of a college and they're
basically trying to produce a scar we
know a heart attack does result in a
scar as shown here this region of the
left ventricle becoming thin as well as
in your is MO and and collectin 3 has
quite a literature to it in studies of
general the general population is shown
here the prevent study from the
Netherlands that there is a relationship
between quintiles of collect and three
in survival so we have a kind of a
general epidemiology that higher levels
of collecting three in the general
population
not necessarily with coexisting
cardiovascular disease predicts over
sufficiently long period of time
survival so they've been epidemiologic
hints that systemic measures of
collecting three are related to outcomes
and then there's been very specific
studies in this study patients with
acute coronary syndromes are being
admitted to the hospital their
pre-existing collectin three level being
related to the relative risk for the
development of heart failure and
relative risks certainly greater than to
catch our eye as you can see here
collect in three levels greater than
nineteen point two had nearly a
four-fold increased risk for the
development of heart failure as a
general rule the population norm for
collecting three level is approximately
eleven nanograms per ml collecting three
is believed to mediate heart failure as
shown in this slide in fact there are
certain patients that we believe it is
the principle stimulus for the
progression of left ventricular
dysfunction fibrosis and all of its
manifestations there have been very good
translational papers that have basically
taken recombinant collect in three and
in large quantities demonstrated its
effects in the heart here's a study
basically looking at animals who have
myocardial dysfunction and these are in
rats who develop heart failure and you
can see those who develop heart failure
have the highest level of gene
expression of collecting three to kind
of carry this further when recombinant
collecting three was manufactured and
then instilled into the pericardium as
you can see compared to placebo it
nearly doubled the amount of
cardio fibrosis that resulted in these
animals in terms of the myocardium so
even epicardial exposure to collect in
three drives fibrosis so this local
paracrine factor is really proven in
interventional animal studies to be
pathogenic you can see here in this
study the intra pericardial
administration of collect in three more
than doubling the amount of collagen
content and then certainly by week four
there's so much collagen content that
cardiac output begins to drop so this is
really proof if you will that I collect
in three is causative in the development
of heart failure and the big advance now
is we can measure this as a lab test in
humans so one could make the case that
this is our first measurable pathogenic
factor in heart failure but there are
other models that are supportive in this
study patients who have a or text enosis
who begin to have a drop in ejection
fraction and have heart failure have
higher levels of collectin three in this
study collect and three has a
correlation not a strong one but a
correlation in humans with the degree of
fibrosis as seen on cardiac MRI after
myocardial infarction
there have been studies trying to
disrupt the gene for collectin 3 and
they've shown in general in models as
shown in the center panel so for
instance the model where cardiomyocytes
are bathed in angiotensin ii which is
very much a pro fibrotic a factor that
attenuating the per the availability of
collecting 3 from a genetic perspective
drops the amount of resulting fibrosis
the same is true with transitory
constriction that's what tac stands for
so pretty strong approved through the
entire tenets of causality if you will
that collect and three is related to
fibrosis in the prevents study as shown
here the the average or mean population
collected three level is eleven
nanograms per ml now we don't know if
this is normal
not because it does go up with aging
this just tends to be a population
measure of central tendency but that
gives you a reference point as you're
looking at values in your laboratory
populations well we have a lot of
information in terms of the prognosis
and heart flavor so this is a longer
section in the Framingham Heart Study is
probably one of the best sources of
cardiovascular epidemiologic data in
this study patients who were free of
cardiovascular disease at baseline had
collect in three levels measured from
blood samples and as you can see here
those individuals in the highest
quartile collected three which
correspond to levels greater than
fifteen point four
they had a market elevation for the risk
of the development of heart failure over
the next ten years they had nearly a ten
percent rate of developing heart failure
and to my knowledge this is the
strongest factor ever measured in the
Framingham Heart Study that predicts the
development of heart failure in and now
it's a simple available blood test to us
so in asymptomatic individuals it
predicts the development of heart
failure and the physicians health study
another supportive piece of information
those individuals per every quartile
increase in collecting three there was a
higher risk for the development of heart
failure so physicians health study
supported what was found in Framingham
the hf action trial a trial sponsored by
the National Institutes of Health of
patients with established heart failure
as you can see here those individuals
now at higher turtles of collectin 317
point eight on up to the highest
quartile gravis twenty five point nine
had an increased risk for cardiovascular
mortality there have been other studies
this one from Europe that have
demonstrated that in patients with
preserved ejection fraction that one
sees a collect and redistribution level
as shown here and there's a star sharp
increase in risk of the development of
heart failure hospitalization and
mortality
in patients with heart failure with
preserved ejection fraction according to
collect in three levels so one of the
teaching points is that collect in three
in terms of its predictive ability for
death and hospitalization has a sharper
relationship in those with preserved
ejection fraction than systolic
dysfunction or reduced ejection fraction
in the coach trial patients who had
higher levels of collect and three had
higher rates of heart failure
hospitalization this was an outpatient
trial in the coach trial the probability
of being admitted for heart fire was
more than twice as likely for those
individuals above a cut point of 17.8 as
you can see here wide separation of the
survival curves and when we organized
what happened to patients in the coach
trial according to death or
hospitalization you can see at very high
levels greater than twenty five point
nine nanograms per ml there's a greater
chance over the next nine months of
death than hospitalization so this test
is has been FDA cleared since 2011 based
on these data as a prognostic aid in
heart failure for both death and
hospitalization here are data from the
corona trial this is a trial of heart
failure patients showing that those
individuals who had collected three
measured at baseline and then had it
measured three months later those who
have elevated levels and it stays
elevated that's the top survival curve
they have the overall worst mortality
what's best is to stay low and stay low
but if patients had excuse me high
levels that reduced by 15% they seem to
have a favorable mortality so these were
the first data looking at serial values
of collecting three it looks like the
earliest time point it could be measured
would be three months or so and that
about a 15% reduction correlated with
improved outcomes okay well all of you
are familiar with the network peptides
that were
fda-cleared in the united states and
part of use i believe in 2000 or 2001
that have many indications for heart
failure and there have been studies that
have measured collecting three and
metric peptides in the same samples and
they provide complimentary information
excuse me collectin three is a marker of
fibrosis while the natural adding
peptides are really markers and
indicators of left ventricular wall
tension and wall tension is determined
by the radius of the chamber as well as
pressure and as you can see here
individuals who have the highest levels
of collectin 3 and the highest levels of
n-terminal pro BNP have very high event
rates in fact they exceed 50 percent in
a year and become nearly a hundred
percent at three years so we measured
these peptides in together in patients
with heart failure because of their
strong prognostic abilities conversely
those individuals who have they're at
the lowest levels of n terminal probiem
p and lower levels of n terminal and
lower levels of n terminal probiem p and
collecting three have the lowest event
rates now the deal heart failure trial
gave us some additional information in
basically demonstrating the idea that if
one has natural peptides as a base and
is looking at individuals above and
below a median that adding collectin 3
to the measurement basically boosts the
prognostic capabilities by about twenty
one percent or so so and many have said
that collecting 3 certainly is a
valuable adjunct to the nitro attic
peptides okay here's another way to look
at it in terms of a 3d plot highest risk
would be collecting 3 above the meeting
17.7 and terminal probiem p above the
meeting and these are european units 253
pica moles per liter
now all the prognostic information has
led to the idea that if we have
sufficient prognosis or we have a
sufficient forecast for the future that
it could actually guide management and
this is very exciting because that's
what we do right now clinically we try
to use our clinical evaluation our
stethoscope and our general clinical
intuition to guide management what i
mean by that is the intensity of therapy
we have now nearly a dozen therapies and
heart failure that can reduce
hospitalization and death and we can't
apply all therapies in all patients
because of the cumulative toxicity and
medication and device burden that we
really have to in a sense assess
prognosis and then apply our therapies
in the most appropriate fashion one of
our important things that we do in
clinical medicine is actually the
frequency of follow-up i think that's
probably one of the most actionable
items and we proposed this in a paper
back in 2011 based on all of the
available data at the time this is when
the test became fda cleared in the
united states and we provided evidence
tables this is just to show you that in
a very assiduous fashion we reviewed all
the available published information as
this was the first paper in the US
literature on this test and we were
impressed by an a meta-analysis which
showed that collect and three clearly
anticipated readmission and these were
in prospective blinded studies nearly
three fold increased risk of admission
when collect and three was above the
median and we also were impressed with
the treatment effects in heart failure
so a primary amplifying of
cardiovascular death non fatal mi non
fatal stroke those individuals at the
highest level of collecting and three
really we're at risk for this
a cluster of complications in heart
failure
many have brought up the idea that
aldosterone is a key mediator of
fibrosis so if any treatment is called
out in particularly in response to hi
collect in three levels perhaps it would
be aldosterone receptor antagonists and
there have there has been a small
prospective randomized trial of
aldosterone antagonism with the
medication called spironolactone which
we do use in heart failure it's one of
the most infrequently used therapies in
heart failure because of toxicities
including elevations in v1 and
creatinine and hyperkalemia but
importantly in this study what was shown
this is a complicated set of figures and
I'll just paraphrase the interpretation
is that spironolactone clearly reduces
active fibrosis in the heart as measured
through pro-collagen one and a variety
of indicators of fibrosis and very
importantly if started earlier seems to
have the bigger effect as opposed to
being started later in a meta-analysis
of aldosterone blockade in patients with
left ventricular dysfunction across all
the randomised trials that was clearly a
mortality benefit with respect to this
form of therapy so I think it's
unequivocal with spironolactone and the
other approved agent of play renowned
that these drugs can be used and in fact
may be the biomarker profile helps best
identify those for benefit here our data
with the lira known in patients with
systolic heart failure and even mild
symptoms so when we segment or subtype
of heart failure population based on
disease the most difficult thing is
really to identify those patients who
potentially really have collected three
mediating or driving heart failure be
compared to those without the only way
to really test it is to measure the the
plasma or serum concentration of
collecting three and as this cartoon
points out we can find patients who
clinically have heart failure but the
collect entry levels are normal and all
the data would suggest they have a
prognosis has shown in the green line
those are the very high levels and I've
had patients with collecting three
levels in this range in example 36.4
those patients no doubt about it over
time we'll have a progressive decline
and B those patients who need the most
intensive forms of therapy and most
frequent follow-up there have been data
regarding collecting three and unplanned
admissions and as you can see here
patients follow very carefully in the
clinic those at the highest level
quartile of collect and three highest
rates of admissions and the reason why
I'm showing you all this data is that no
matter where the patient populations
have been measured whether it be in
North America in South America or in
Europe we can almost always find values
of low risk at at or below eleven and we
can almost always find elevated risk
above seventeen it's been enormous Lee
externally consistent among studies and
so this led us to this idea that we can
actually you know practically use
collecting three and heart failure and
develop a case experience and what we
found is that we can use collecting
three to identify increased risk for new
onset heart failure and healthy
middle-aged adults is shown in
Framingham we can to predict heart
failure in patients after acute coronary
syndromes we can help establish the
diagnosis of heart failure with
preserved ejection fraction in patients
presenting with exercise intolerance so
in my view it has also some diagnostic
capabilities for us and it certainly
aids in the prognosis of heart failure
with preserved and reduced ejection
fraction which is its strong suit and
which one it's FDA approval so based on
all of this in 2011 we proposed this
algorithm which shows that stable class
two to class for heart failure that we
see in the office where the diagnosis is
confirmed we've had elevations in PRP
and n-terminal Pro BNP previously helps
solidify the diagnosis that those
individuals are shown in green at with
level less than 17.8 nanograms per ml
our practice is to see these patients in
a usual care a timeframe typically every
three months patients in this middle
zone here seventeen point nine to twenty
five point nine we still see the
patients yet about that same time
interval every three months but we begin
to intensify their therapies move up on
doses of medications start to intensify
the overall program and greater than
twenty five point nine my practice
banners as I see these patients once a
month or sometimes more frequently and I
absolutely push all of the intensive
medical therapies to the limit we know
that greater than twenty five point nine
there's very high risks way over fifty
percent chance of death or
hospitalization in six months nearly
certain at twelve months and and we know
that we can follow collect in three
about every three months if we see a 15%
reduction there's an improvement in
prognosis 15% increase or worsen
prognosis so this algorithm has been
proposed and it's largely held up in
clinical practice one could debate the
cut points but you the idea is there's a
general understanding that these are all
levels well above the population norms
and they are strong indicators of
prognosis so to finish and conclude
collecting three is a measurable key
mediator in the pathogenesis of
myocardial fibrosis I think that's
proven the fundamental mechanism by
which heart failure progresses elevated
collected three in the general
population and in patients post mi is
associated with the future development
of new heart Geyer irrespective of
ejection fraction elevated collected
three levels indicate increased risk of
mortality and heart failure
rehospitalization is shown in every
study today where it's been measured
collecting three is independent of and
complimentary to the network peptides as
they measure separate and distinct
biological processes so we use them
together it's not an either-or
proposition given the very high rate of
short-term events heart failure patients
with elevated collected three levels
should be considered for advanced care
management's
jeez in my view particularly those above
25.9 nanograms per ml so I believe
that's my last slide oh no I just have
one case study before we open it up to
questions or comments and we had
recently published this with a
multidisciplinary group including some
European colleagues as well as some
nurse practitioners and it was one
patient that I had in my practice to
give you a real live example a 64 year
old female who had a history of a large
anterior wall MI and I forget when she
had it she was very sick and we had her
in the coronary care unit did acute
angiography and intervention she was on
a balloon pump that was now about three
years ago she was intubated at the time
she'd be covered and seeing the office
yes ejection fraction of 30% in class 3
heart failure she has a history of type
2 diabetes is not required medications
hypertension kidney stones
she had atrial flutter we did an
ablation on that she had an ICD
implanted with the atrial flutter she
had an embolic stroke and she's been on
anticoagulants she's recovered from that
I really invested a lot of my
professional time and energy into her
very reliable patient in the officer
blood pressure's 94 over 68 so I don't
have a lot of room to work with
medications she's at a regular rate of
60 was actually paced rhythm clear lungs
diffuse point of maximal impulse she
does have an s3 and she has considerable
edema so she's tough to sort out I mean
she tells me she's doing okay but her
exam tells me she's not on routine
chemistry's and this is just a snapshot
of the electronic medical record to give
you an idea of what it looks like her
probiem p levels are high but they're
always chronically high and then you can
see the BU and in creating here which
just like the blood pressure are kind of
guardrails for how much we can intensify
therapy her echocardiogram and this is
her echocardiogram shows
and interior an apical thinning and
fibrosis and a reduced ejection fraction
30% the ventricle is dilated there's
mild much of education which is expected
the estimated pulmonary are systolic
blood pressure is elevated the left
atrium is dilated and the real question
is what to do with their medications
well I ordered the collectin three level
and it was twenty point eight so it fell
into that moderate zone where the
suggestion is we really ought to try to
maximize the ACE inhibitor or ARB help
reverse with vertical remodeling and as
previously suggested also try to
optimize the mineralocorticoid receptor
antagonist one of the considerations is
that collectin three could actually be
behind some of her chronic kidney
disease as well or diabetes really never
was as much of an issue she's not
hypertensive and as shown here in this
Uriel obstruction model collecting three
just like a dozen the heart collecting
three is promotional arenal fibrosis
okay and although collecting three is
not FDA cleared for assessment in
chronic kidney disease I think it's
important for the clinicians to know
that there is a literature suggesting
that if collected three is knocked out
in this model that in fact there's much
less fibrosis neglect in three is almost
certainly positive so in this patient we
really can declare her in a sense a
cardio renal syndrome type two where the
heart failure seems to be driving the
chronic kidney disease she has a high
end terminal probiem being collect in
three so I was able to start
spironolactone something I probably
wouldn't have based on her skin
creatinine but I was really prompted by
the the laboratory result kept her
enalapril at a very low dose and
unchanged that would be kind of my
second medication to change all the
other medications were unchanged because
of their limits in terms of blood
pressure and BIA when in creatinine but
it did make the point that
that collectin three really indicated a
very poor prognosis and and helped guide
some of her management so I'm gonna go
ahead and stop here and I will turn over
control to those who are Judy and those
who are managing the platform and I'm
gonna look for questions now to respond
to them
thank you dr. McCullough for that
informative presentation before we get
started on the question-and-answer
session I would like to remind our
audience how to submit questions you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green to an A button at the lower
left of the presentation window we'll
try to answer as many questions as we
can and our first question is please
explain the similarities and differences
between the EMP and galectins three
well that's an important question the
BNP an n-terminal probiem P as our
natural addict peptides are very
different than collect in 3 B n P and n
terminal probe E&P come from a common
peptide called pre-pro BNP and they are
secreted by heart muscle cells
themselves so they are in a sense a
heart hormone they are directing the
heart to relax and the kidneys to
excrete salt and water fibrosis that's
occurring in the heart is being directed
by galectins 3 collectin 3 is not
secreted by heart muscle cells but it's
secreted by support cells called
macrophages collectin 3 is directing
scar formation and fibrosis in the heart
so doing something completely different
than a direct peptides collecting is
prognostic rather than predictive and
levels change slowly over time once
elevated how does this affect serial
measurements
well you can imagine there's a
population of macrophages and their
total efforts are producing the plasma
concentrations of collecting three that
we measure
so unlike the network peptides which
have a very rapid upregulation sequence
on chromosome one collecting three does
not have a rapid response at all because
it's really directed towards healing
just like your if you cut your skin your
skin doesn't heal within a matter of
minutes or seconds it takes days well
for collecting three plasma
concentrations to change it takes
literally months and so the implications
are when we have a collect in three
level we certainly shouldn't measure it
the next day in the next day it should
not be used for serial testing in the
hospital it can be used for testing and
hospitalized patients but just one
sample is fine whether it be the
admission sample a discharge sample it
simply doesn't change over the course of
a hospitalization and then in practice
we want to give enough time for patients
in the office to have a fair chance at
improving collecting three levels so my
practice is to wait a minimum of three
months sometimes six months before I
check it now on each and every patient I
do follow the American Heart Association
and American College of Cardiology
guidelines and I do make sure that
galectins 3 is a measure that is
obtained in those patients just like a
cardiac EKG an echocardiogram the
guidelines strongly support the
measurement of collecting 3 as a
standard in the evaluation of patients
with heart failure do you recommend
serial measurements
yes I do recommend serial measurement
certainly not in the hospital but we do
measure in the office in typically three
to six months after we have a baseline
measurement you do want to get a sense
of in our patient to the best of our
understanding are they getting better or
are they getting worse and in my view
because Gluckman 3 is very stable is
probably one of the best chronic
measurements of whether or not a patient
is actually changing in terms of the
progression of heart failure what would
be the differentiated treatment for
patients with higher concentration
levels of collectin 3
well because galectins 3 is a pro
fibrotic factor and we believe that
macrophages are responding to the neural
hormonal environment I think the two big
drivers are angiotensin 2 and
aldosterone and as the slide suggested
drugs that basically attenuate the
effects of angiotensin 2 that would be
ace inhibitors or angiotensin receptor
blockers or drugs that directly block
the effect of aldosterone that would be
spiral spiral lactone or a player known
I think those therapies are the ones
that speak best to elevations in
collectin 3 and I I believe putting
together everything we know from
clinical trials and what's available in
the trials that have actually measured
fibrosis suggests that would be the the
best clinical response how about the
interference from fibro CC of other
organs such as liver fibrosis well I
think that's an important point that was
raised
collectin 3 is not cardiac specific so I
should be very clear about that it's one
of a family of galectins like I said
there's I believe about a dozen or so
galectins and so any internal organ
process of which there's fibrosis going
on including liver fibrosis in the
setting of cirrhosis as well as
rheumatologic diseases where there is
joint fibrosis
there can be elevations of collectin 3
in certain forms of solid tumors
collectin 3 can be elevated but it also
can be depressed and so I think some of
the most confusing literature on
collecting 3 is actually in the cancer
literature but in our patients with
heart failure and I published I think
some of the earliest data on this the
important points our heart failure has a
very cause specific pattern of mortality
and hospitalization
and has been shown in patients with
heart failure the leading source of
collectin 3 is in fact the heart is
physically coming from the heart and not
from other sources and in a patient with
heart failure I think the only only
point patients we could really get
confused on are those who have cirrhosis
and considerable ascites or those who
have widely metastatic cancer or
uncontrolled rheumatologic diseases
those patients who have overlap of two
major disease entities like that are
sufficiently rare so one should be
cautious if you have a patient like that
but what you need to know is patients
who have heart failure the vast majority
of the cases that collect in three is
directly coming from the heart this next
one may be a two-parter to which extent
could collect in three marker be used in
a general population or some specific
patient populations the test is
fda-cleared specifically in patients
with heart failure as a specific
population my personal view is based on
the Framingham Heart Study and the
physician the physicians Health Study
the most intriguing data sets are
actually middle-aged adults who are well
where elevated collect and three levels
predict the development of heart failure
and so many of us are interested in
heart failure prevention we previously
have had no tools to actually identify
those individuals at risk for the future
development of heart failure the data on
collect and three are very strong there
I would not be surprised in the future
if that becomes a major use of collect
and three in the prediction of the
development of heart failure because we
do know that that we have therapies that
can be markedly reduce the risk of the
development of heart failure as a
syndrome including drugs that block the
rena angiotensin system
what are your thoughts on using collect
entry in helping improve readmission
well there's been a lot of trials and a
lot of efforts to reduce readmission
what we know is that high-touch high
frequent contact works there's been
randomized trials there's been
meta-analysis there's no doubt about it
if we could see all heart failure
patients and see them frequently all the
time we could have a massive reduction
in heart failure hospitalizations the
problem is that's not scalable that we
simply don't have the resources to
intensively manage all the heart failure
patients so a use of collectin 3 is to
help identify those individuals who are
at the highest risk and it's typically
about 25% of the population we could
call them out and then and those
individuals really set up the frequent
follow-up set up home care nursing in
some cases even home care home physician
visits and intensive forms of therapy we
could really make a dent in the problem
so I stood I think a strong suit of
collecting 3 there's a very stable
marker is to measure it in office
patients and identify those patients who
look pretty good to us clinically but in
fact are gonna wind up in the hospital
with a hospitalization over the next 30
60 or 90 days
is collecting without BNP value useful
yes so collecting three is fully
independent of BNP results and and and
no doubt about it is is useful
BNP is a good moment to moment our to
our predictor or indicator of wall
tension and so we use BNP in titration
of diuretics as an example we certainly
use it as terms of its diagnostic
capabilities but BNP has a tremendous
variation it needs to double on the way
up to indicate a significant decline and
reduce by 50% on the way down to
indicate improvement and so it's not
very sensitive in terms of telling us
which direction patient is is going in
my view of collecting three is a much
more stable entity it doesn't change
much and so when we do see changes we
are very confident that patients are
either worsening or improving are there
specific cut-offs between men or women
or is there only one cutoff
now unlike the natural peptides which
there are clear gender differences and
women tend to run higher than men with
collectin 3 there's really only one cut
point for both men and women in terms of
risk determination so it's been shown
that you know the majority of studies
suggest that risk begins in healthy
individuals begins roughly at 13 and
then clearly among patients with heart
failure risk begins at a level about 17
or so and they apply to both men and
women patients with heart failure
measurement of st2 helps to risk
stratify to assess treatment options
monitor progress and to guide in
hospital and post discharge care how
does collect and 3 compare to st - well
st - is another laboratory test that is
fda cleared in the assessment of
patients with heart failure it has a
very different origin though st - is
produced by the endothelial lining of
the left ventricle and the aorta cough
low tract and st - appears to be a decoy
protein so it interferes with the normal
signaling of interleukin 33 on
interleukin 33 receptors on
cardiomyocytes and so st - in many ways
can be viewed as a indicator of
biomechanical strain a very different
than collecting 3 which is an indicator
of fibrosis the data suggests that if
there's a form of therapy that's called
out with st - it's really beta blockade
which actually influences bio made
mechanical strain so in my view I think
st 2 is very complementary to collect in
3 they
reflect very different biologic
processes and and the accha guidelines
also indicate that st2 along with
collectin 3 along with the natural
peptides are all cleared by the US fda
and indicated and useful and studies in
assessing the prognosis and making that
link to management in chronic heart
failure patients what is the influence a
renal failure on collecting three well
as I alluded to in the case there are
data to suggest that galectins 3
produced by the heart actually may be
causative in the development of chronic
kidney disease in patients with heart
failure now that's a speculative
statement but there's more and more data
suggesting that in the cardio renal
syndrome or heart failure leads to real
fire that collect and 3 may play a role
collectin 3 we believe is cleared by the
reticulo-endothelial system so it has
kind of a diffuse mechanism of clearance
and the vasculature I having said that
there's one study that found in patients
with dialysis that they have some of the
highest measurable collect in three
levels that we've seen in mankind
approximately 60 picograms 4 ml and so
my personal recommendations would be to
not use collect and 3 in dialysis
patients until we understand more about
what it means we do know to Alice's
patients have some of the thickest and
most fibrotic hearts in all individuals
in internal medicine but to our
knowledge collecting 3 is not doesn't
rely on renal function for clearance but
in fact it may be causative in the
progression of chronic kidney disease on
you know on the road to the development
of the need for
forms a renal replacement therapy what
is the best published systemic review
article regarding collecting three
well I'd point readers to two documents
one is one that our group published in
reviews in cardiovascular medicine in
2011 which summarized in evidence tables
all the available studies up to that
time that measure collect in three and
the second document would be the two
2013 American College of Cardiology
American Heart Association guidelines
particularly the biomarkers section
which also summarizes the data on
collected three those were the
evidence-based documents on the use of
collect and three in patients with heart
failure having said that I recognize
that those papers are now somewhat dated
it's 2015 there's been a lot more
published on it and I think we probably
are due for another comprehensive review
of the published information on
collecting three because the additional
studies have given us more insight
particularly on the cardio renal
interactions and also do provide more
support for its use in the applications
of the risk prediction for the
development of heart failure as well as
heart failure management given the
requirements for serial measurements in
collect in three three to six months is
it important to use the same lab method
well I'm glad the laboratory method
question came up because there's been a
recent advance so since 2011 the test
has been available through what's called
a microtiter plate technology and what
that meant is largely we had to send a
test to reference laboratories where we
would get the result back days or even a
week or two later so even in all the
centers I worked at we actually had to
have collected three as a send out test
collect and three has recently been made
into a convenient automated form of an
assay it's available on the Abbott
Architect platform which is the one that
our hospital and many hospitals across
the world use and so now for the first
time collect and three will be an
in-house test and and we'll get great
degrees of consistency with the central
laboratory platform the microtiter
platform across different reference
laboratories I imagine could have
variation to it my experience would tell
me though that the results are fairly
consistent from lab to lab collecting
three could be used for monitoring
effectiveness of heart failure patients
treatment with the newly approved
entresto
while we're very excited about two new
market entries for the pharmacologic
treatment of heart failure one of them
being entrust Oh which is excuse me
which is the crystallization of two
separate compounds one is called Sakura
Bertrille which is a neutral and
depended ACE inhibitor and the other one
is valsartan an fda-approved therapy for
heart failure angiotensin receptor
blocker but at lower doses and what we
know here is that entresto changes the
biomarker milieu in patients with heart
failure considerably and we anticipate
given its very dramatic effects on
mortality and hospitalization that in
fact in may indeed impact levels of
collecting three levels of BNP go up
slightly about 20% with entresto
initially for the first two weeks and
then begin to fall and terminal pro BMP
levels begin to fall and what we may
find out is that those patients who are
are improving in fact also have a
reduction in collecting three and more
importantly those who may not be
responders to entresto may have elevated
or increasing levels of collecting three
those are just conjectural statements
we'll have to see but we're very excited
about about the new medications and
heart failure particularly in trusts oh
and future studies certainly we'll be
reporting out collect and three response
to and trust oh and then changes in
collecting three with administration of
the medication that concludes the QA i
would like to once again thank dr.
McCulloh for his presentation do you
have any final comments dr. McCulloh
well Judy I want to thank you and the
organizers of the web cast including
Abbot Diagnostics in lab roots and thank
you each and every one of you for
attending we hope this is an efficient
way of getting updated on advancements
in the laboratory medicine and
particularly this one which is very
clinically relevant to internal medicine
Hospital medicine and certainly in
cardiology on heart failure and stay
tuned to more information as it comes
out with a collectin three and probably
more widespread implementation of
collectin three now that it will be
available on central laboratory
platforms in laboratories across the
country and across the world and so I'll
let that be the last word and again
thank you for attending this webinar I
would also like to thank our sponsor
Abbott for making today's educational
webcast possible today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
March 22nd 2016 you will receive an
email from lab roots alerting you when
this webcast will be available for
replay we invite you to afford that
announcement to your colleagues who have
missed may have missed today's live
event and I just want to remind people
that you can receive seee credits for
this session so again thank you for
joining us today see you next time
goodbye